faut bien le dire le rappeler les 200000
françaises et français qui travaillent
dans le secteur du nucléaire c'est une
chance parce que c'est ce qui nous
permet d'être le pays en europe
qui est parmi ceux qui émettent le moins
deux tonnes par co2 par électricité
produite
nucléaire par qu'hydro et notre base
installée
nous devons ré investir pour être à la
pointe de l'innovation de rupture dans
ce secteur ça passe par une série de
familles technologiques m'appartient pas
ici de l'est de les trancher est celle
ci ne sont pas en quelque sorte
exclusive des choix industriels qu'on
doit faire aussi à plus court terme sur
à la fois le nucléaire et les énergies
non renouvelables mais nous devons
absolument nous préparer à des
technologies de rupture et
transformations profondes sur le
nucléaire la promesse de ce qu'on
appelle les small modula reactors qui
sont les les petits réacteurs beaucoup
plus modulaire est beaucoup plus sûr
parce que la sûreté est un point clé du
débat sur le nucléaire les technologies
pour mieux gérer nos déchets certaines
sur lesquels nous commençons à avancer
certaines que nous n'imaginons même pas
avec là aussi un travail fait par nos
organismes de recherche qui pour
certains sont déjà très avancés par nos
grands industriels historiques et par
aussi d des entreprises de taille
intermédiaire des start up et des pme
françaises qui sont en train de proposer
des innovations de rupture en la matière
pour le iiie parvenir nous devons ouvrir
le jeu de manière totalement inédite et
nous sommes prêts à y investir un
milliard d'euros d'ici 2030 en
commençant très vite avec des premiers
projets très clair et donc là il faut
lancer plusieurs projets sur des
familles technologiques différentes mais
essayer d'avancer pour accélérer sur ce
volet c'est absolument clé parce qu'on
sait qu'on continuera à avoir besoin de
cette technologie est au fond on doit
traiter de sujets clés améliorer
toujours et encore la sûreté en baissant
les coûts et réduire les déchets qui est
un point clé quand on parle de nucléaire
deuxième objectif
devenir le leader de l'hydrogène vert en
là je le dis en l'assumant totalement
repensé à fait partie vraiment d'un des
secteurs où nous pouvons être leader
c'est une vraiment une filière dans
l'énergie où nous pouvons encore le r
parce que nous avons des atouts on a un
premier atout c'est encore une fois le
nucléaire
pour produire de l'hydrogène il faut
l'électricité parce qu'il faut faire
d'un électro lise et beaucoup de
d'élèves que d'ingénieurs donc j'ai
l'impression de dire à des gens qui
savent beaucoup mieux que moi comment ça
marche mais je le dis pour pour ce soit
clair parce que sinon on perd de vue de
nos débats donc on a besoin de faire de
l' électrolyse sa consomment beaucoup
d'électricité
si on produit de l'hydrogène
en utilisant du énergies fossiles ça
sert à rien
on peut produire enfin produire de
l'hydrogène en important des
renouvelables mais aujourd'hui compte
tenu de l'électrification des mobilités
que l'europe de toute façon à décider
pour elles mêmes il n'est pas vrai qu'on
aura une énorme production n'aura jamais
en europe suffisamment de production de
renouvelables pour faire nos grandes
électrolyse et produire de l'hydrogène
vert et donc il ya en fait deux grandes
stratégies de production d'hydrogène
vert il ya une stratégie qui consiste à
aller faire les em les énergies non
renouvelables pardon pour faire lé
électrolyse très loin et réimporter
l'hydrogène ainsi produite un peu comme
on fait avec le gaz dit fier il ya une
deuxième stratégie qui va être le coeur
de la nôtre nous on fera les 2 qui va
être de d'essayer d'en produire beaucoup
chez nous parce qu on a la possibilité
de faire de l'électro listre est
décarbonée